aside from celebrate what should a
screenwriter do once they've finished a
script that you know I I had someone
asked me this question it was so good
because I said you know I'm gonna put
that into my upcoming seminars because I
think the biggest question of the writer
is what's next
and I actually the interesting thing is
and I did I wrote a first chapter of a
book that will be coming out on writing
that I'll have posted on my my website
and everything when it does come out it
is ten actions a writer can take so it
really goes into this I think there are
a number of things the writers can can
do once once the script is finished
number one you want to think about how
big is your writing portfolio so many
writers will finish the very first pilot
and think that they're going to sell it
and the chances of that are so rare it
has happened I have seen it happen but
it is so rare so I think it's having
knowing when it's time for you to take
the next step very often the next step
of having a script done is right what's
next what are you going to write next
and what does it look like say it's the
fourth script you've written in your
portfolio is now done so then what do
you do next
then it is writing a creative bio is
what I encourage my writers to do so you
can go into now certainly writers who've
entered the writing programs like an NBC
ABC CBS Warner Brothers they know what
that creative bio looks like because
very often that's the essays that they
have to fill out in these writing
fellowships so it is similar to those a
creative bio is like a resume but it has
your voice and you're telling a story
and
and you're giving people an opportunity
to get a sense of who you are and so I
encourage writers to write a creative
bio
then to enter as many competitions as
they can if now this is for the writer
who doesn't have a strong contact base
this is for the writer who really is now
for the writer who has a strong contact
base then it is writing a list of
everybody and anybody who you think
would want to read your script and what
I tell writers is recognize that there's
a mutual benefit going on when it comes
to asking someone to read your script if
you are asking someone who needs to know
strong writers and you believe you're a
strong writer then there's no favorite
going on there is a mutual benefit going
on so I can't tell you how many writers
will say to me I've had writers where
I'm like okay like you're ready now
you're ready
you've got your portfolio done you're
you've got some of them already have an
agent and manager I'd say 50% of the
writers I work with have agents and
managers already so now it's moving
forward and the writer needs to operate
like an entrepreneur they need to
recognize that even if they have an
agent and a manager they have to go out
and make things happen and and and it is
a partnership that is going on there
so I think once the script is completed
I the writer who's newer I encourage
entering as many competitions as
possible so that you have a reflection
the competitions if you make it to the
quarterfinals or the semifinals are the
final list it tells you where your
script is and that is knowledge and
information
like you don't want to send your script
out if it's not ready because the
biggest mistake writers make one of them
is sending the script out before it's
ready and grant it I'm going to tell you
every script could go through
development forever and it just that's
what it is but you also have to know
when it's in a strong enough place to
where it's going to make a strong
impression
you